- I'm instantly regretting my decision.
(dramatic music)
- I am bleaching my armpit hair.
- This is so ridiculous.
- It doesn't hurt, but
it's a little spicy.
- Oh man, this is gonna get all over me.
- My armpit looks like a tennis ball.
- I'm just marinated in blue dye.
- Maybe some people do
it because it's funny.
I'm doing it because it's funny.
- Or maybe some are
doing it as a statement
about standards of female beauty.
- The dyed armpit look is
sort of a way of saying,
"It's my body."
- It's like, you don't like
women with armpit hair?
Well let me take it one step farther.
Let me put some neon colors
on this mother (bleep).
Blow it in your face.
- If you feel secure in your body,
you're not worried
about what people think,
then why not try it?
- Do I groom my armpits?
No, I do not groom my armpits.
I've had these my entire life.
- I groom my armpits, I
just keep them manageable.
- I don't groom my armpits.
I mean, I put on deodorant,
but these babies just kind
of take care of themselves.
(dramatic music)
- It just looks ridiculous.
- My armpits look like
the head of a troll doll.
- The more I see it, the funnier it gets.
- I definitely feel like I'm
from the capital of The Hunger Games.
- There's nothing I could do to fix this.
(laughter)
Does anyone know how long it
takes to grow armpit hair?
Because I sure don't.
What if this takes 10 years?
- I'm going to Catalina Island tomorrow,
with my girlfriend's parents,
and they're gonna be like,
"Oh, who's this freak?"
- Having this kind of makes me feel like
if I had a tattoo in a naughty place.
Am I doing this for other people? No.
I'm doing it for myself,
and it feels pretty good.
(dramatic music)